c'était une grande première au
Technocentre Renault de gu en cours une
campagne de recrutement dans les
secteurs de l'ingénierie des produits
était organisé aujourd'hui dans la
structure ivelinoise à la clé une
trentaine de postes
Renault a annoncé le recrutement de 1000
personnes 500 personnes pour les usines
de fabrication et 500 personnes sur les
activités ingénierie et tertière et donc
nous nous employons évidemment à donner
satisfaction à tous les besoins que nous
avons euh sur nos directions et sur nos
métiers au total 70 candidats
présélectionnés sur CV ont passé des
entretien de 50 minutes avec des
managers il s'est focalisé sur les
attentes du poste pour lequel on cherche
le candidat pour ma part avec un peu
plus de recul j'essaie de regarder euh
le potentiel du candidat et et sa
capacité à assurer une employabilité sur
le long terme et regarder ce qu' pourra
apporter à l'entreprise Renault au-delà
du poste pour lequel on cherche à à
recruter à l'instanté une fois la
journée terminée les recruteurs se
réuniront pour statuer sur les candidats
les réponses seront données dans les 48
heur ça peut être bien surtout pour les
personnees qui qui comme moi postule à
un moment donné ils vont pas trop
attendre quoi l'attente c'est pas très
très bon pour quelqu'un qui postule je
trouve ça bien ça me si si si j'ai
réussi je féliciter tout de suite si je
suis pas pris je veux continuer pour
pour mon cherche l'emploi dans le futur
de nouvelles journées de recrutement son
organisé avant l'été la prochaine
session est programmée le 24 mai
prochain cette fois-ci plus de 80
candidats sont
attendus